let's say I want to multiply 3 point 1
or 3 and 1/10 times times 2.4 which can
also be described as two and 4/10 so
pause the video and see if you can do
this once again I'll give you a hint see
if you can express these as fractions so
there's a couple of ways you can express
it as a fraction you could express this
as 3 and 1/10 times 2 and 4/10 to the
same color 2 and 4/10 now whatever your
multiple these are mixed numbers right
over here and mixed numbers are not the
super straightforward to multiply it's
easier if they were written as what's
often known as improper fractions but
essentially not as mixed numbers so 3 is
the same thing as 30 tenths so 30 tenths
plus 1/10 this is 31 tenths times 2 is
the same thing as 20 tenths so 20 tenths
plus 4 is 24 times 24 over 10 and
hopefully this makes sense to the 3.1
this 3 right over here
this is 30 tenths or I could write all
over at 30 tenths and this is 1/10 so
this total is going to be 31 tenths
likewise this 2 is 20 tenths plus 4
tenths gives us 24 tents and now we can
multiply so this is going to give us our
denominator is pretty straightforward 10
times 10 is 100 and then 31 times 24 we
can multiply it in the traditional way
that we're used to multiplying two-digit
numbers 31 times 24 is going to be equal
to 4 times 1 is 4 4 times 3 is 12
now we're going to be multiplying in the
tens place we're going to put a 0 here
so 2 times 1 is 2 we're really saying 20
times 1 is 20 but you get the idea
2 times 1 is 2 2 times 3 is 6 really 600
because it's
times 30 but I'm just following the
standard multiple the method for
multiplication then you add these and
you're going to get four four seven so
when you multiply these two things
together in the numerator you get seven
hundred and forty four hundredths which
can also be expressed as this is the
same thing as seven hundredths over let
me or seven hundred hundredths I should
say plus forty four hundredths and seven
hundred hundredths well that's just
going to be equal to seven so this is
seven plus forty four hundredths which
we could write as 0.44 that's our seven
and forty four hundredths and we would
be done and you might already be seeing
a pattern if you just took 31 and
multiplied by 24 you get seven hundred
and forty four and notice I have one and
two digits behind the decimal point
notice I have one and two digits behind
the decimal point and so think about
whether that always works think about
and why that might work if you just
multiply the numbers as if they didn't
have decimals so you have gotten seven
forty four and you say hey I got two
numbers behind the decimal so my product
is going to have to have two numbers
behind the decimal why does that work or
does it always work and how does it
relate to what we did here which is
converting these things to improper
fractions and then multiplying it that
way